welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the podcast that gives
you too much information about what type
of horror movie threats you should be
most afraid of this halloween season
slashers gnashers or paranormal crashers
yeah when you rhyme an ash sound three
times it means your house is going to
burn down
oh yeah not the hard way i like that
i'm eric boss here with me it's tommy
bechtold how are you doing man
oh i'm good i think i'm most afraid of
uh born again christian's house is on
halloween on trick or treat night
that have the signs that are like jesus
loves you no candy this year
that was as a chubby little boy those
are the places i was most afraid of what
are they gonna do to me in there what
are they doing if they're not
trick-or-treating or bobbing for apples
or carving pumpkins they're praying
right now
i did the thing i said i wouldn't do
sorry john uh
anyway have a spooktacular halloween
everyone i gotta go
bye everybody well tommy look i don't
know about you but uh tis the season for
replacing much needed sleep with uh
constant nightmares that james wan is
gonna make a conjuring movie series
about me
uh but not all horror movies are the
same
some center around serial killers
stalking babysitters in suburbia
others are more grounded tales about
ghosts and curse videotapes yes
so what is our big question this week
well eric with that in mind i want to
know
what types of horror movie villains are
the deadliest i'm talking ghosts and
demons or is it the slashers
or could it even be monsters yes those
are kind of our three categories of
threats in the horror movie world right
uh
whether you're watching paranormal
activity should he be more afraid that
it's a demon or a ghost should i be more
afraid of
the ghostface killer from the scream
movies yeah should be afraid of zombies
what category is the deadliest well this
episode we're gonna break down
each of those three categories taking
three candidates per category
and look at the movie kills they have
in their film series their film
franchise
total kills and based on that deadly
number
we're going to see which category is the
deadliest sounds good to me
all right let's start with our first
category
so we're going to start with our man
pennywise aka
it from stephen king's it films based
off of
other accounts we've been able to find
35 kills on screen though
as many as uh an additional 611
and an additional 18 000 maybe we'll get
to it
so in chapter one of course we start
with georgie denbrough
and then uh the bully patrick hofstetter
there are also past missing kids
including eddie cochran
we believe he loses an arm because uh
pennywise waves that severed kid arm at
them across the creek
and then there's betty ripsom who in the
first movie
her top half is shown and then the
bottom half in that same door you see
the severed legs walking toward them
so i think she was ripped in half and
then there are 26 other floating kid
bodies in that sewer they lit later
flush out with henry bowers in chapter
two
yikes you'll float two you'll float too
you lied and i die but then moving on to
chapter two we start with the death of
adrian mellon
um thrown over the bridge and then
anyways thinks he's up in them out of
water but then like bites them in the
ribs
stanley eures slits his own wrists i'm
gonna attribute that to pity wise
because it's the fear the paralyzing
fear of pennywise that led him to do
that
the poor little girl vicky her head was
bitten off under those bleachers
and no one noticed bleachers aren't that
thick
but yeah whatever and then there's the
kid dean who at the skateboard he was
killed in the fun house
and then at the end of the movie poor
eddie kasperick was impaled by a spider
pennywise
now these are the ones in the recent
andy muschietti uh bill skarsgard movies
but estimates from the novel of
pennywise's past skills way more people
are listed as dead in the novels you
have the
the factory explosion the easter
explosion
the black spot fire the bradley gang
massacre the original massacre of the
dairy township and the colonial times
uh add all those up you get about 600
kills from the past in derry
decent amount of kills right there
that's a lot of bodies
yeah pretty good but as many as 18
000 kills assuming we're doing some math
here a consistent ratio of deaths per
capita
every 27 years dating back to the town's
colonial era
yeah we're starting out with some big
numbers for the ghost stevens
i mean anyways pennywise takes a lot of
forms but he's essentially the demonic
entity of evil
yes terrifying oh god those movies
the original terrified me so much my
aunt had a copy of the book on her
bookshelf
that i would cover up or turn the other
way so that i couldn't even
read the words it yeah oh that scared
the hell out of me too in blockbuster
they would have the tim curry cover of
just the clown appearing
in the corner of it and i was afraid to
go down that aisle i was afraid to just
even look at it if i could see it in the
distance i would get uh
the terrors yes um but let's go back to
one of the original boogeyman boogie man
freddy krueger from the nightmare on elm
street series we can attribute to him
36 kills i'm gonna just quickly run
through in the first
nightmare on elm street he killed tina
slashed across the chest he killed rod
uh hanged with a bed sheet glenn lance
our man johnny depp
pulled into a bed eaten by the bed blood
geyser amazing moment
and then marge burned to death and then
descended the abyss in 1985's freddie's
revenge
more people are just stabbed some pool
party kids are stabbed and then
nightmare on upstream three dream
warriors uh that's the one
with future
oscar winner patricia arquette oh yeah
yeah these kids are all like in a
sanitarium so
there's some really insane deaths here
yeah but like what's fun about freddy uh
you gotta watch just a montage of all of
his kills because they get
insane in the dream master
uh sheila's breath and perhaps organs
are like sucked out by freddy
uh debbie started to a cockroach and
crushed in uh
the dream child the fifth movie dan is
turned into a motorcycle
excuse to a motorcycle and crashed into
a truck those geico commercials
were really harkening back to a simpler
time
yeah that's the same movie where this
guy mark was turned into a paper
kind of like the aha music video and he
was slashed and crushed his ass
[Music]
moving on to the next movie freddy's
dead the final nightmare 1991
a lot of uh people died as well here
including loretta krueger who was
strangled to death
and then we didn't see freddie for about
a decade until freddie versus jason his
uh final film appearance
and this one he he killed far fewer
people than jason did a little girl off
screen
he killed lori's mom but he only got
three in that movie
that's how you get all of his kills um
not a whole lot
but we'll move on to someone who i was
shocked by how many people she killed
samara the ghost from the ring
yeah so in the first movie not too many
people just uh just a handful of people
including
poor anna morgan she kills that guy in
his uh video lab
which you know we work in similar labs
it makes me afraid
of leaving screens on for too long oh
yes me too um also a poor horse
died in that movie and you never want to
see one of those not unless you're
not unless you're a dothraki then
killing horses is badass
cut them in half
in the ring two really only uh three
people were killed by samara but
in a movie that i wasn't really sure
existed 2017
rings ah yes a [ __ ] ton of people die
and mainly attributed to about 75
or so people in a regional jet that
crashes as a result of samara's haunting
so the grand total for samara is about
91
or so kills plus a horse that brings our
total category for
the ghost demons as at least 172
kills right for these three maybe uh an
additional 611 an additional 18 000.
that's a real plus minus for this we
should call gallop and let him know
we're getting good data here
so you have a lot to fear from the
ghosts and the demons but
all these people really only died
because of a specific curse that you
could argue they themselves
are guilty of by not moving out of
freaking dairy maine
i couldn't agree more the most
frustrating thing for me as a as a kid
watching horror movies was
the lack of judgment i was like a very
nervous kid i was not like a daredevil
so it was always like why would you ever
go in the basement why would you
not immediately leave once the first
person was killed in this town under
suspicious circumstances it's like
you know i didn't understand the
economics uh even harder to understand
the motives behind is our next category
yes slashers because yes these are the
serial killers who kill without reason
you really can just be in the wrong
place at the wrong time or be paul rudd
and you could die from these we're going
to start with one of the
deadliest slashers in film history our
man michael myers
not shrek although he's his farts are
pretty deadly michael myers from the
halloween series donkey
donkey breathe it in donkey i'm not
taking the seat off your head
give god um okay so michael myers has
killed
121 people on screen which seems like
wait did he just go
nuts in one movie well he went nuts in
like 20 movies
he's been in so many damn movies he's
the michael caine of michael myers
starting with 1978's classic halloween
john carpenter
he really only killed five people in
this movie he killed judith myers as a
child he killed a mechanic when he got
out of the
asylum and then he killed uh lori
strode's friends yeah she also kills
some dogs but lori strode gets away
yes good for her halloween two takes
place the same night
and michael continues killing spree he
goes to the hospital where laurie is he
kills a lot of doctors a lot of nurses
hospital explodes at the end of it
michael doesn't appear in halloween
three but he does uh come back in
halloween for the return of michael
myers
where he kills 15 people targeting
laurie's daughter jamie this time
there's a city-wide blackout he just
kills a ton of people that are in his
way and he ends up falling down a mine
shaft
happens happens it happens it happens
especially there's a blackout you want
to leave those
lamps especially on halloween the amount
of times i've ended up in a mine on
halloween
baker's dozen at this point moving on to
halloween five this is the revenge of
michael myers he kills 12 people he
targets jamie again he kills her foster
sister
rachel kills a bunch of cops in this one
now in uh halloween
the curse of michael myers 1995 this is
technically halloween 6 starring
our man paul rudd scott lang so in this
one uh lori's daughter jamie is now
pregnant she's abducted by michael
sets out to kill more family members of
the myers home michael turns
against uh there's a cult and he turns
against the own cult members and just
kills
every member of it yes paul rudd's name
in that movie was tommy i believe
it was yeah
i just like hearing my own name i'm a
simple man eric
[Laughter]
we'll work it in we're working more i
think there's a tommy and the jason
franchise as well so you'll have
some of them that brings us to halloween
h2o 20 years later 1998.
this is a direct sequel to halloween and
halloween 2. it kind of ignored the
other sequels in between
and this one michael targets lori 20
years later she's the
headmistress of a private school but he
only really kills six people in this
movie kills people who work at the
school kills her boyfriend kills her
son's friends but she gets away and then
halloween resurrection 2002 he kills 10
it begins with
lori in a sanitarium and um michael
actually kills her in this movie
he returns to haddonfield and he finds
his house being used for an internet
live horror show and he kills everyone
in it because
why would you why would you make that
people don't want that kind of i don't
understand type of curiosity
to me is you deserve to be murdered at
that yeah oh for sure
don't poke the bear if you do poke the
bear you best not miss that's right
yeah absolutely omar that's the phrase
omar did say that absolutely
so five years later rob zombie rebooted
the halloween franchise with just
2007 it's halloween and this is i think
michael's deadliest
film appearance it's a super super
violent he's a point of view character
it's kind of an origin story michael in
this uh remake he kills his sister and
her boyfriend
and like a school bully kills his mom's
boyfriend he just kills everyone he kind
of see like his violent tendencies
throughout his life and then they kind
of replay the events of the original
halloween he kills laurie's uh friends
and he kills lori's parents and this led
to halloween two
follow-up to that movie in which he
kills uh 13 people one year later
he kills the rest of lori's friends at
another halloween party
and in an unrated cut uh dr loomis is
killed as well and in this movie michael
and laurier revealed his siblings as
well
oh yes and the final halloween movie
that we've had so far is uh
another kind of reboot the more recent
2018 halloween movie
yes written by danny mcbride and david
gordon green i believe
yeah and john carpenter actually came
back for this one his son scored it i
believe and i think a carpenter was a
producer on it
and it was pretty great i really enjoyed
it and a sequel to it halloween kills is
coming
out next year it's pretty cool it's a
direct sequel to the uh 1978 original
it doesn't even factor in halloween two
i don't think it just kind of picks up
after that moment louis looks over the
balcony and he's no longer there one of
the best film indians by the way ever
but
lori is his badass recluse who loves the
second amendment and
michael goes looking for her finds
lori's granddaughter
and then yeah it ends with like three
generations of strode women who are
fending them off it's it's a pretty
yeah third act still gets still kills 16
people though so not bad
yeah not a bad not a bad not about kill
some podcasters
so look out ooh well i don't like that
that's to me is too far when it
personally affects me
i don't like it i'm gonna quickly run
through another slasher just because i
was
shocked by how many that this guy killed
so chucky from the child's place series
has apparently killed at least 70 people
on screen
or people who are part of his family
have killed 70. so in the first child's
play he kills four people
including using a voodoo doll on someone
that was pretty awful
yes in the second movie child's play two
he kills people
he kind of loves using a toy making
machine to do that he punches
the eyes in their head and child's play
three that's the one where he targets
the kid andy where he's at a military
academy and he has a memorable scene to
put in live ammo and guns
yeah piece of [ __ ] yeah um he's just
naughty yeah he's a naughty naughty
little toy
and then we get a great leap forward in
1998's a bride of chucky where he teams
up with tiff
and uh they just murder a lot together a
seed of chucky was in 2004 they have
you know their son glenn is now joining
the family we got the curse of chucky we
got the cult of chucky
and then in 2019 we had the remake with
aubry plaza child's play in which
chicka killed five i was unaware that
curse of chucky and cult of chucky
existed so
yeah i was like an adult watching horror
movies at that point i don't know how he
missed those those ones
completely slipped by me though the one
that came out last year did not but i
did not see it yet but i will now
now we're gonna get to a guy with a
staggering level of kills jason voorhees
we've talked about him before on the
show
he has killed 157 throughout the friday
the 13th film series and a lot of this
is because there have been so goddamn
many friday the 13th movie
right right pretty much every year in
the 80s there's a new friday the 13th
love it now the first friday the 13th
jason actually isn't in that one that's
mrs voorhees is a killer camp crystal
lake she kills 10
people but jason does come in friday
13th part 2
where uh he kills some new counselors
including the original survivor alice
that's the one where he has a shrine of
his mother's head
but he's not wearing the hockey mask yet
he's wearing a burlap sack mask
it's not until friday 13th part 3 where
we get our first appearance of the
hockey mask
there's more camp crystal lake
weekenders at a nearby vacation home
that he kills
and then in 1984 we get probably 13th
the final chapter
nothing could be further from the truth
that's where he targets the jarvis
family and their neighbors
and then tommy kills jason by driving a
machete into his head
all right but the franchise must move on
uh because in 1985 there's friday the
13th a new beginning
jason is still dead but tommy jarvis
is now targeted by a new killer named
roy burns
a lot of people were killed but many
people consider it non-canic it's not
really a jason movie but then the next
year
we get friday 13th six jason lives
jason's back to life i love that in two
years they were like
this is it this is the last movie maybe
we'll do a sequel to that movie but we
won't have jason in it
we changed our minds jason's all the way
back and it was like he's only back it
was
it was 24 calendar months that this
thought process played
not only is he back tommy now he's got
superhuman powers
via electricity i think and uh returns
to like kills 18 more people there and
the franchise just gets better and
better from here yeah he comes back
again friday 13th part seven
in 1998 that's the new blood he kills
15. he is set free
after being chained at the bottom of the
lake there's a teenage girl using
psychokinetic abilities
freeze him he goes on another killing
spree and a movie ends with that girl
summoning her dead dad
back to life to drag jason back down to
the bottom of the lake nice
it's a fun one 1989 is part eight jason
takes manhattan that's where his corpse
kind of gets shocked back to life by
teens on a houseboat
yeah and then he rides that boat to new
york city
and then kills people in times square
eventually gets stuck in the sewers
as you do oh it happens to all of us
yeah happens to the best
now the ninth one is jason goes to hell
the final friday
in that jason gets blown up but his
spirit possesses the quarter's body
and he continues killing yes yes do it
and then we went about a decade without
a jason movie until we got
jason 10. i remember this this was buck
you want a beer or do you want to smoke
some pot
or we can have premarital sex he killed
21 people
this is the one that's in the future
jason's body is brought in studied by
the government in the year
2455 he is thawed
out on a way to a new planet it kills
everyone on board the space station and
he becomes a cyborg at the end of course
he does
of course he does now in 2003 and the
title we've talked about already
freddie versus jason jason does the
lion's share of killing and technically
this is kind of a follow-up to the
ending of jason goes to hell that's
ninth movie
that movie ended with a hand that came
out of nowhere and dragged him to hell
and this movie it's revealed that hand
belonged to our man freddy krueger
they battle but people get killed in the
crossfire
um it happened and now in 2009 they
tried to reboot the series with just
friday the 13th
it's kind of like a new origin story he
kills vacationers at camp crystal lake
uh 14 people die
so there's kind of two timelines we're
gonna lump them together give them 157
total kills
bringing our slasher total for this
category
348 kills but they're still out there
tommy
they could be killing more oh my gosh
there's also like the fans of jason
voorhees are like the most devoted
horror fans like they make like 90
minute professional quality
fan films that are pretty
indistinguishable from
from some of the studio produced ones i
mean it's truly incredible
all right we're now moving on to our
third and final category the monsters
we're lumping in some aliens in here too
but most monsters you could argue our
biological experiments gone awry
as most of the time zombies are so we're
going to start with
the xenomorph from the alien franchise
we're just counting the original
xenomorph for the queens xenomorph we
met aliens we're counting
every broader species member or genetic
offshoot
of this original as we learned in
prometheus engineer experiment
but we'll start with the classic my
favorite film of all time
alien in 1979 not too many people die
it's really just a nostromo crew
kane brett parker lambert dallas but we
can also
retroactively count the one engineer in
the derelict spacecraft
aliens now that's a fun one a lot of
marines die in this one
frosty trick grove where's bowsky
opponent drake spokemeyer
pharaoh hudson carter burke that piece
of [ __ ] bastard carter burke you
dogged me pal you also have to count the
158 colonists of hadley's hope now newt
was a member that she survived this film
but her brother timmy and her parents
were implied to have died that brings us
to alien three
uh david fincher's attempted rescue
operation of this film not that bad
overly hated but also not that great
this one opens with it being revealed
that newt and hicks died in the pod
crash i'm gonna count them i'm gonna
count because they wouldn't be in a
situation for one for the xenomorphs you
alien [ __ ] are gonna
pay for this so a lot of these uh prison
colony people die
just a ton of them do a total of 29 die
um but not david finch's career is just
beginning only just begun yeah
what's in the box god bless that man uh
that brings us to alien resurrection
film our man joss whedon helped create
to get off this boat ah 22 people die
in this one there's like a bunch of
evacuees uh there's a couple different
versions of the xenomorph that are doing
the killing here a bunch of crew members
get cocooned
a lot of people die and for a while this
seemed to have put the alien franchise
to
death until 2004 alien vs predator
[Music]
xeomorph kills 11 in that and that film
was so successful it uh spawned
alien for spreader requiem i think my
favorite title which had one of the most
horrific
scenes of all time when he goes through
the hospital and goes through the infant
ward
oh what the hell was that that was not
okay that's the scene that killed
that spin-off franchise xenomorph kills
18 in that one and then we kind of had a
reboot which they didn't tell us was an
alien prequel but it obviously is an
alien prequel prometheus
yes and eight people die mostly due to
stupidity
just because someone got infected and
then everyone acted like they had never
taken biology 101 before
correct but yeah the goo was behind it
all right and we got a lump in that last
engineer there that final scene was
pretty sick
yeah i got it i gotta hand it to that
one yes and that led to the sequel alien
covenant
in which 11 people died there were also
a couple different versions of the
xenomorph here
we had the neomorph we had the
protomorph a lot of people died
including was revealed the
survivor of prometheus dr elizabeth shaw
died in that one as well
so a lot a lot of people died from the
xenomorph okay that brings us to
uh another john carpenter film the thing
1982 which
was itself a remake but one of the best
horror films of all time
combined with the 2011 prequel which was
not as good
uh the thing the alien shapeshifter and
assimilator of that franchise killed 19
people uh which i just want to include
on this list because i think it's
one of the coolest uh monsters yeah if
not the coolest i
freaking love the practical effects in
the 1982 john carpenter the thing
at least eight are killed and that's
what's so amazing
about this genius film is you never see
certain characters get assimilated
and at the very end you're left with uh
with mccready and you don't know if
either the two of them are uh
assimilated maybe both of them are maybe
neither of them are but you can't really
trust it and there's
lots of little clues in there that some
people think that mccready gave him
uh gasoline and then when he took a sip
of it he didn't know
and that's how mcgrady knew and that's
why he laughs you know i i love
love love love this movie so the thing
opens with norwegian scientists in
antarctica
chasing down a dog and in the prequel
you meet those norwegians those poor
poor norwegians 11 of them die
now it's worth noting that in the 1982
thing blair's computer projected that
if the thing reaches civilized area
total world population would be
assimilated within
27 000 hours that is about three
years in 1982 there were an estimated
4.6 billion people on earth
i just love that little moment it's just
like a little flash on screen that just
gives you
the apocalyptic stakes of this game ever
leaving the antarctica
and that brings us to our final monster
the ultimate monster the king
of the monsters godzilla
yes from the touhou films uh we are
going to be counting i know
you godzilla fans are gonna be so mad at
us for doing this uh we're counting the
2014 reboot in 2019 king of the monsters
just because there were
countless uh great classic touhou films
and it's almost impossible to count but
we're able to look at the two more
recent films
486 human characters die in those two
recent films
but many estimates of people trapped
under rubble of the areas that were hit
of the relative level of evacuation of
those areas estimate that around 1.5
million people
probably died from the kaiju of those
films
so that would put the monsters total at
777
potentially upwards of 1.5 million
though that's why we have a huge margin
of error here
but it does give you a sense of the
scale i think i was surprised by many of
the numbers on this and i think
our ultimate conclusion is that while
the supernatural abilities and nature of
ghosts and demons are
in a lot of ways the most mysterious and
scariest
you're really only likely to be killed
by those kind of things if you invite
the curse onto yourself somehow
either by selling your soul at some
point or by
living in dairy maine yes uh slashers
i would say are far more dangerous
because uh they never
seem to die and you could just be in the
wrong place at the wrong time and end up
in a michael myers um
deathstroke yes but by far no matter
what you do you are statistically most
likely to be killed by an
alien or a monster some kind of creation
of humanity or some kind of thing from
another world
that's gonna take you out so what do you
think of all this tommy which one of
these are you most afraid of now
i mean i have always been afraid of
monsters
always aliens and and things hiding but
i think
the thing i have an irrational
confidence that i could evade a slasher
i don't put myself in dangerous
situations
i'll tell you what though you get cursed
it's over for you
it's over for you i i feel like an
extinction level event i could still be
one of the survivors
but if i get cursed if samara from the
ring comes for me it's over see you
later bye i get a lot of screen time
i answer all phone calls because you
never know when hollywood's calling with
your big break
she could call me and whisper three days
and that would be it for me
well when i hear a scratch at the door
or a bump in the night
i'm gonna hope it's a it's a slasher
because you're right if it's a curse
it's like i've done something
yeah or a family member did something
yeah and i deserve this that's true
sometimes it's just your family screwing
you over
which nothing's scarier than family
the ultimate killers the mom's text is
coming from inside the
i house not changed my underwear and i
won't i'm a grown boy i don't have to
no no one can make you do that unless
you want to
we want to move on to some people who
helped us make this episode our friends
at purple mattress
you probably think all mattresses are
basically the same well the same
goes for pillows whoa peel away the
layers
look what's inside and you will see they
are not all
created equal that's what makes every
purple pillow and mattress unlike
anything you've ever slept on
so if you look closely there is like
kind of a honeycomb grid going on here
the purple grid is what sets the purple
mattress apart from every other mattress
it's a
patented comfort technology that
instantly adapts to your body's natural
shape and sleep cycle i i i'm feeling so
much stress relief just holding
on to this like it's it's so beautiful
what's happening yes
with over 1800 open-air channels
designed to neutralize body heat purple
provides a cooling effect
other mattresses cannot replicate and
this cutting edge technology doesn't
stop with the mattresses
every purple pillow is engineered with
the grid
for total head and neck support and
absolute airflow so you're always on the
cool side of the pillow isn't that great
yeah
excellent purple's proprietary
technology has been innovating comfort
for over
15 years and i can really see it in this
purple pillow which is both a fun
tongue twister to say and also just the
best pillow i've ever had
it's super comfortable and is supportive
and it makes my delicate little noggin
feel super cozy while i rest they try to
put a helmet on me as a baby
i didn't want to wear the helmet as a
baby you can't put a helmet on
perfection you only put a crown on that
head king
my kid you can try
every purple product risk-free with free
shipping returns and purple has
financing available as low as 0
apr for qualified customers so
experience the purple grid and you will
sleep like never before
just go to purple.com big question 10
and use the promo code big question 10.
that's 1-0
for a limited time you'll get 10 off any
order of 200
or more that's purple.com big question
10 promo code big question 10
for 10 off any order of 200 or more
terms apply
nice nice nice i'll take a little nap
snoozy poo on that as soon as we're done
but we still need to investigate some
more questions
tommy we're going to move on to a
bite-sized question that you're gonna
answer are you ready
yes all right we're gonna go back to the
discord with our good friend civilian
who asked a wonderful question
in the captain america civil war cap
beat iron man
who was wearing his mark 46 armor with
bucky's help
if cap fought solo would tony have won
great question civilian and uh the
answer i have is yes the most
valuable upgrade in tony's mark 46 armor
is the ability to analyze caps
fight pattern to deploy automatic
counter measures knowing what your
opponent's gonna do
mirroring him like link in legend of
zelda ocarina of time only thwarted by
the deku
seeds the first move tony gibbs
after that algorithm kicks in knocks
kemp's shield out of his hands he wrecks
cap cap didn't have a chance
tony's only blind spot during this fight
comes from bucky buckley nearly rips out
his chest reactor which
as we know is uh what he needs to
survive and it's bucky
who distracts tony long enough in the
final moment to trip him up giving cap
an end to lift tony's body and body slam
him
much like bane body slamming christian
bale ending the fight
remind order butter
that's my name you hear the name man i
guarantee the pain
i wish he had said that however tony
wouldn't fight cap solo tony was only
fighting cap because cap was protecting
bucky that's true there's no version of
this conflict where it's one-on-one
cap versus iron man fight it's always at
least two on one
and that's why cap wins because he knows
whether the avengers win or lose they
gotta do it together
okay like us whether we whether we get
a million views or just 10 views from my
mom hitting refresh
i can't believe what they're doing
they're getting paid for this
oh dear lord whether we got people
sharing this video with a thumbnail
is kappa virgin asking what the [ __ ] is
this channel talking about
and we get almost cancelled on twitter
for it yes we do it together
[Music]
that's right nobody stares into the
abyss that is cancel culture on twitter
like you and me my friend
well let's stare into the abyss of our
box scraps
one question the question this week
staying on brand is what movie has given
you the most
nightmares i love this question i love
this question
i you know as an adult i've seen a
decent amount of horror movies
and those are all scary but i think you
know once your brain kind of matures to
a certain level
you can kind of parcel it out and enjoy
the experience so for me
the movies that gave me the most
nightmares were the movies that i saw
that were weird as a kid so like
something meant
as family fair a movie like little
monsters with howie mandel and fred
savage
oh [ __ ]
made me afraid to sit in couches to
lay in bed by myself hello ladies
uh to go downstairs alone
go down into the basement alone all of
these things made by this movie that was
for kids it probably upset me worse than
anything the horror movie
that stayed in my head the longest was
the original evil dead by sam raimi i
saw that when i was like 11 at my aunt's
house
should not have seen it at that age i
might even been younger
and like i know that it's kind of a
campy you know
low budget movie but wow did it mess me
up for
a long long time i mean it made me
scared to go outside during the day
you know yeah i can see that that movie
i i totally agree
uh is the fact that it was so campy i
think it's part of it's a horrifying
charm
yeah for me for me um i've talked about
this with
uh people on discord before there was
like a period around 1998 where
i think we just had like a cinemax and
hbo free trial so i watched everything
that was on tv
around then and i saw the movie what
dreams may come
and i saw the movie event horizon happen
at the same time and
they bummed me out i almost say they
scared me they just bummed me out yeah
i experienced depression for the first
time just this existential dread of like
wow there really is something on the
other side and it's not this sweet lovey
angel thing that i've been told in
school
it's like horrifying yes
awful now it is
time to go back i know
to hell you know nothing hell is only a
word
what dreams may come screwed me up too
yeah that was another one yeah it
affected me so emotionally
probably i've had more nightmares about
that kind of thing than i have about
like
you know watching scream
[Applause]
and layered too if you think about it
because the star of what dreams may come
is robin williams who is such a
who is such a familiar comforting face
for kids mr flubber is going to hell
but you're right that definitely gave me
some like real life adult
depression and anxiety of like yeah what
am i doing
here right but i think the things that
give you the most nightmares as kids are
when horror moments come out of nowhere
and i think for me the first experience
of that was who framed roger rabbit
right oh
yeah you
oh my god we re-watched that recently
and i'm like oh i just had like
uh flashbacks too yes so as a kid that
definitely screwed up my sleep pattern
well let us know what movie has given
you the most nightmares in the comments
below we want to hear from you what
scares you the most out of things we've
talked about
it is the time to talk about it so we
get it out of our system and
that is our show this week tommy it's
awesome
being scared with you i love being
scared with you eric it's fun to be
scared and it's all right to be scared
and as long as you're scared and i'm
scared
we're the burton ernie of fear all we
gotta do is just hug each other and hug
our purple pillows oh come on purple
pillow hook me up
nice we'll get you one we'll get you one
all right
now a reminder to join our official
discord server all you gotta do is
become a patron at patreon.com
new rockstars you can get an audio
version of this show by subscribing to
new rockstars big question wherever you
get your podcast
you can send us your big questions on
twitter using the hashtag bigquestion
but yeah we'll we'll check our discord
first for
for those big questions we'll try to get
through all of those follow me at eavos
follow tommy tommy bechtold follow new
rockstar social subscribe here on
youtube to get too much information all
stuff you care about mommy did you hear
that
you know what i didn't i didn't hear
anything i'll go check the basement
i'll be right back
[Music]
you